اتوجه الى الرباط حيث وصل المنتخب المغربي
قادما من الدوحه بعد ان توا صفحه مشرقه في
تاريخه الرياضي عندما انهى مشاركته في
مونديال قطر 2022 في كره القدم بحلوله
رابعا اثر خسارته السبت الماضي امام
كرواتيا اثنين مقابل واحد في مباراه تحديد
المركز الثالث على ملعب خليفه الدولي اسود
الاطلس حققوا افضل مشوار في تاريخ
المنتخبات الافريقيه وكذلك في تاريخ
المنتخبات العربيه
وهذه هي الصور مشاهدينا الكرام اذا
الحافله التي تقل اسود الاطلس والتي ستجوب
شوارع الرباط امام الاسود الغفيره لمناصر
اسود الاطلس كما ذكرت بعد مشوار تاريخي
مشرق جدا في مونديال قطر لكره القدم معي
الان في الاستوديو الزميل فوزي بن جامع
للتعليق على هذه الصور التي يمكن ان
نعتبرها صورا تاريخيا بقدر النتائج التي
حققها منتخب المغرب في مونديال قطر كما
ذكرنا حقق افضل نتيجه
وافضل مشوار في تاريخ المنتخبات الافريقيه
والعربيه
اسود الاطلس الذين كتبوا التاريخ في قطر
الاحتلال المركز الرابع في مونديال سيبقى
راسخا ب تاكيد في الاذهان في عند جميع
المنتخبات العربيه والافريقيه منتخب
المغرب الذي فتح كما يبدو شهيه المنتخبات
العربيه من اجل المشاركه مستقبلا ليس من
اجل المشاركه فقط وتخدي تخطي الدوره الاول
فقط ولكن من اجل اللاعب للدوره ربع
النهائي للدوره النصف النهائي لان يحلم
مره اخرى بالوصول الى الدور النهائي
ولمالات تتويج مستقبلا في بطوله عالميه
كبيره مثل كاس العالم نتابع هذه الصور
المباشره وهذا الاستقبال الشعبي الحافل
لاسود الاطلس من قبل همم المواطنين في
المغرب لاحقا سيكون هناك تكريم من قبل همم
ملك المغرب محمد السادس الذي وجهه ايضا
همم قبل ايام دعوه لامهات اللاعبين لتكريم
هند ايضا في همم
عنده في في الرباط طبعا التكريم تكريم
مستحق وهو واجب ان صحه تعبير بالنسبه
لاسود الاطلس الذين قدموا مستويات كبيره
في هذا المونديال في مونديال قطر نسخه
تاريخيه واستثنائيه بالنسبه لقطر التي همم
التي نظمت هذا المونديال ايضا بالنسبه
للمنتخب المغربي الذي فاز على منتخبات
كبيره نتحدث عن بلجيكا وكندا واسبانيا
والبرتغال وايضا الخساره امام منتخب فرنسا
في نصف النهائي وايضا المركز الثالث امام
المنتخب كرواتيا في المباراه الترتيبيه
نتحدث ايضا حينها عن همم لعنه الاصابات
ايضا التي طالت المنتخب المغربي نتحدث عن
الجاهزيه البدنيه في مباراه مباريات صعبه
جدا في مونديال قطر مباريات في ايام قلي
لكن لمنتخب المغرب بقياده المدرب وليد
الرجراجي استطاعوا ان يحولوا الحلم الى
واقع وتجاوزوا الادوار الاولى ووصلوا الى
الدوري نصف النهائي من حق المغاربه من حق
العرب من حق الافارقه ان يفتخروا بهذا
المنتخب الذي يصل الى الرباط وخرجوا هنا
لتحيتهم مشاهده تحيه المتبادله بطبيعه
الحال لرفقاء ياسين بون والمتالق في هذه
الدوره وعز الدين مناحي لاعب اونجي متالق
ايضا والعديد من اللاعبين الذين ابانوا عن
مستويات مميزه جدا في بطوله تاريخيه
واستثنائيه في قطر هذه الحشود تنتظر
كمعلمنا منذ الصباح الباكر ونشاهد
اللاعبين هنا على المباشر طبعا مع رئيس
الاتحاد المغربي همم فوزي لقجع الذي
يرافقهم في كل صغيره وكبيره ويقدم الدعم
للمنتخب المغربي الذي وصل الى هذا المستوى
المبهر كريمه صراحه ولكن بعد سنوات من
العمل والاجتهاد
ترى اسمه باحرف من ذهب في النسخه الاولى
في الشرق الاوسط من مونديال كره القدم